pablo man congratulations good to see
you again thank you so much how you
doing carlos i'm doing good man you know
fans have been waiting for this series
for a long time like a life-changingly
long amount of time but for you i'm
curious about like between wrapping
production and like premiering it at
south by what was the emotional journey
like for you like what were those
emotions as you're about to show people
the product of all your hard work oh
it's been amazing you know there's so
much lead up to this as you said there's
so much anticipation you know from from
halo fans certainly who have waited so
long for this adaptation
um and you know one of the main things
that that we wanted always was uh for
for fans to feel like this is a universe
that's familiar uh that they're gonna
know right away um and it's just a new
way of interacting with a familiar
environment uh and then you know on top
of that for people who have never seen
the show i'm really excited because for
me you know i've become a halo fan over
the course of the last three years uh in
researching this role and getting into
this role um and really learning about
the the depth of the mythology that's
been established for me it's so exciting
uh to get to show this to a whole new
group of fans of people who maybe don't
know the game and haven't been exposed
to it but to get to show them why we all
love this universe so much
one of the big topics of conversation
was like you know are we going to get to
see who master chief actually is
underneath the helmet and we do
really early on
and it would have been such a shame for
you to wear that whole thing the entire
time because we're like pablo is master
chief we can't hide this man's face but
what were the conversations like around
that was there ever the conversation
like are we are we gonna see me i'm
gonna be in this whole time
no it wasn't a conversation uh about
seeing me it was a conversation about
what was right for the story and what we
wanted to talk about the themes that we
wanted to attack uh you know one of the
biggest things we want to do here master
chief is a symbol right he's a symbol
for for bravery and courage under fire
having a sense of humor in the most
difficult situations every one of us who
have ever played the halo game have put
ourselves in the shoes of the master
chief so there's a co-ownership that
comes with playing playing the video
game you really helped create the
experience right so we always knew it
was going to be that it was a loaded
subject and that it was going to be
challenging for some people but at the
same time to make a television show
we knew that we also wanted to that a
huge part of our show was going to be
about the tension and the dynamic
between master chief the soldier and
john the human right who's inside and
that the old you know one of the big
themes is is the effect of war on
society and the effect of war on the
individual right how much of of his
humanity does he have to give up in
order to do his job and how much of his
sense of duty or patriotism does he have
to leave behind in order to feel fully
human and those themes of humanity and
of the effect of war on humans you can't
do from inside the suit you know you
really have to get inside the suit meet
the character and it is that tension
between the john between john and the
master chief and him getting to know
himself that we wanted to attack and so
it was always uh it was always going to
have to come off
for sure uh we loved the picture of on
instagram that you posted with you and
your son on set with one of your sons
there taking taking it all in what was
his reaction to see everything that was
going on on set and what was the
reaction to seeing you in costume yeah
it was huge man um i mean you know my
kids haven't had a real close
relationship to my work space yet
because um you know most of my
characters are in adult shows that they
can't watch yet so this has been a real
joy because it's the first one that i've
been able to sort of bring them into the
process
um bring them to set show them the set
and obviously you know um if dad's
playing master chief that's that's going
to be an appeal to
anybody uh under 14 and i have two kids
under 14. so um it's been really cool to
bond with them on that
now you said you'd become a fan of the
game over the course of you know
becoming master chief yourself so like
on a scale of one to five like one being
newbie and five being master chief if
you're dropping in
on a game of halo infinite like
how are you performing what's your level
uh
my gaming level is low i'm not even
gonna lie i'm not gonna brag you i need
a lot of practice i'm still working on
that part uh the one thing i learned
early on is that you don't have to be a
great gamer to be a good actor or a good
storyteller
and the parts you know that that really
really do affect my job or is the
research you know and is getting to know
the material uh and i made it a real a
real point very early on to to go deeply
into obviously the cinematics of the
game all six of the mainline games i'm
very familiar with the performance of
steve downs as the voice
in halo legendary guy with a legendary
performance he's really brought the
character to where it is now um and i
have a ton of respect for that
and really getting to you know
immersing myself in as much lore uh and
mythology as i could through all the
different mediums that it's been
presented in uh and those are the parts
you know that that make me the halo fan
i'm a fan of story i'm a fan of
mythology i'm not very good at playing
video games you know but but but that's
not necessarily a skill that
that i need for uh for going into battle
as the master chief
right on i love that hey man
congratulations again uh excellent work
and listen maybe we'll see you in in one
of the lobbies one day who knows i'm i'm
open to it come scope me out let's have
a longer conversation buddy let's do it
all right cheers thank you
you